oh i was smiling we all agree that
avatar the last airbender is one of the
greatest shows of all time
we loved watching aang save the world
from the fire lord of zai
zuko go through his amazing redemption
arc and all of the funny saka moments
but have you ever wondered how the
creators brought the show to life
we've got the answers wow
to create the fantastic bending we see
in avatar the last airbender
the animators had a few tricks up their
sleeves tricks like reference footage
reference footage is when actors will
act out the animated scenes in front of
the camera so the animators can go back
watch the footage and replicate what
they see on paper
let's look at how sifu kisu the
choreographer brought the elements to
life
for avatar the last airbender sifu kisu
decided to use real martial arts
techniques to create the different kinds
of bending we see in the show
how cool is that airbending was inspired
by the movements of bhagwa
both airbending and bagua rely on
circular motions
and while the movements may look calm
both styles are a force to be reckoned
with
as for water bending the style was
influenced by tai chi
according to sifu kisu waterbending is
less about power
and more about body alignment and breath
just like tai chi
for fire bending kisu decided to utilize
the techniques seen in northern shaolin
this form of martial arts just like fire
bending is
powerful and dynamic just look at the
arm and leg movements of both styles
last but certainly not least is
earthbending
general earthbending style is based on
hangar
earthbending and hungar are more about
their strong stances
and the connection the body makes with
the ground that makes sense
after all earthbending is all about the
bender connecting to
well the earth there is one earthbender
whose style is not based on hungar but
chalgar can you guess who it is that's
right it's tough
toff is such a unique and powerful
character that she gets her own style
chao gar is a more rare form of martial
arts
it's tougher and works better for short
range fighting
the choreographers thought that this
would be appropriate for toff because
unlike the other earthbenders we see in
the show she's blind
and frankly your earthbending could
still use some work too
this will really make you watch the show
differently check out the concepts that
the show started with
before making massive changes to create
what we know and love today
first let's start with how different
aang momo and appa looked
this is what the creators originally
came up with momo looks like some kind
of robot and oppa looks more like a big
dog than a bison
we can't imagine what the show would be
like if the showrunners had stuck with
these character designs
another big change the creators made
happened in uncle iro instead of being
the lovable
wise and kind man we know he was almost
a hardened war
general can you picture how different
the show would be
lastly let's talk about toff did you
know that originally she was supposed to
be a big bulky man
that's right think of the boulder
another avatar character fans love
imagine toff looking like that of course
they do make a joke about it in the
ember island players episode when toff
is portrayed as a big man what you
thinking about
one of the best parts of avatar the last
airbender is the characters themselves
what would the show be without aang's
optimism and saka's humor
they wouldn't be the characters we know
and love without the people voicing them
alright here's the deal aang is voiced
by zach tyler eisen
his voice is perfect for the character
who balances being mature and
being a goofy kid katara was brought to
life by mae whitman
she made sure to bring katara's motherly
instinct and strong character to the
forefront when voicing the character
sukkah's voice came from jack desenna we
were surprised to learn that saka wasn't
originally meant to be the humorous guy
we love
the creators had intended him to be more
serious but when jack desenna started
recording for the character
he brought some funny attributes to the
character
find by me if you're not gonna do your
job
zuko is voiced by dante bosco now we all
started off against zuko
since he was only after aang but as the
show went on
we learned his backstory and we watched
one of the best redemption arcs of
all time unfold he's a fan favorite for
sure
this is what basco had to say about
voicing the character
act from my heart and hopefully the
voice lands in the right place
toff's voice is provided by jessie
flower we all know
top as the best earth bender of all time
but what does the woman who voices her
think
during a panel someone asked flower what
her favorite line to record was
as you might have guessed i am not top i
am melon we
love avatar the last airbender for so
many reasons
from the animated perfection to the
gripping story to the characters we know
and love the show is practically perfect
which behind the scenes moments
surprised you the most be sure to let us
know down in the comments
thanks for watching